Muchos nos habéis pedido un vídeo sobre
las protestas de Colombia y creo que os vamos
a sorprender.
Hemos tardado varias semanas en sacarlo porque
hemos querido ver todas las aristas de este
problema.
Hoy vamos a hablar de impuestos, de la policía
Colombiana y de algo que seguro que muchos
de vosotros, incluso los que veáis este vídeo
desde Colombia, no conoceréis: la doctrina
Damasco ¿A qué me estoy refiriendo y qué
tiene que ver con toda esta historia?
Al final del vídeo lo entenderéis todo ¡Vamos
con nuestra historia!
Colombia es un país con dos caras.
Por desgracia, todos conocemos la mala: los
narcos, el terrorismo y la pobreza.
Sin embargo, existe otra cara mucho mejor.
Colombia es una de las economías más estables
de todo Latinoamérica.
Por ejemplo, Colombia nunca ha experimentado
hiperinflación y tienen el mejor historial
crediticio de todo Latinoamérica: desde 1930,
el Gobierno de Colombia ha devuelto siempre
sus deudas.
En los últimos años, han ¡Y sí!
¡Ya lo sé!
Nada de esto son cosas espectaculares… si
no fuera porque hablamos de un país latinoamericano.
Es decir, comparado con Venezuela, Argentina,
Brasil o incluso México… ¡Colombia no
está tan mal!
Sin embargo, todo esto ha cambiado con el
CoronaVirus.
Colombia ha sido uno de los países más afectados
del mundo: no en pérdidas humanas sino también
económicas.
En este contexto, el Gobierno ha subido los
impuestos.
Y esta subida de impuestos ha provocado protestas.
Y lo que podría haber sido una protesta sin
más, ha terminado en una auténtica catástrofe.
Atentos.
Colombia eleva a 47 los muertos en las protestas
contra el presidente Duque
Y aquí entra el debate que tienen ahora los
Colombianos: unos dicen que la policía colombiana
es ultra violenta.
Otros dicen que los manifestantes son violentos.
Incluso algunos políticos colombianos como
el ex presidente Álvaro Uribe han llegado
a decir que hay grupos terroristas infiltrados
en la protesta.
Así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es
¿Quién tiene razón?
¿Por qué Iván Duque quiere subir los impuestos?
¿Y por qué es tan importante la Doctrina
Damasco en esta historia?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes... antes os tengo que hablar de LATAMPOLITIK.
Muchos nos pedís que hablemos más de Latinoamérica.
Y por eso hemos sacado nuestro propio boletín
especializado en geopolítica de Latinoamérica.
Por sólo 5 dólares al mes, es decir, lo
que cuesta un menú Big Mac en Bogotá, recibiréis
3 correos electrónicos todas las semanas
con nuestros análisis sobre geopolítica
en Latinoamérica.
En LatamPolitik descubriréis muchas cosas
de las que a duras penas se hablan en los
medios convencionales.
Por ejemplo, descubriréis todos detalles
de la pugna entre China y Estados Unidos por
los recursos de Brasil, o por qué Rusia tiene
tantos intereses en Argentina.
Dicho de otra forma, que si os suscribís
a LatamPolitik no sólo estaréis apoyando
a VisualPolitik sino que también accederéis
a información muy difícil de encontrar por
otros medios.
Tenéis toda la información en latampolitik.com.
Y ahora sí, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
EL AGUJERO TRAS LA PANDEMIA
Os voy a hacer una pregunta, y os aseguro
que no vais a saberme responder ¿Cuánta
gente paga impuesto de la renta en Colombia?
Pensadlo bien, hablamos de uno de los países
más poblados de todo Latinoamérica.
Tienen una población que supera los 50 millones
de habitantes ¿Cuántos de ellos pagan impuesto
de la renta?
Pues, en el año 2020, hablamos de sólo 1.6
millones de personas.
Y diréis ¿En serio?
¿Pero cómo es posible?
Por si alguno lo estaba pensando, no, la respuesta
no es el fraude.
Veréis, la mayoría de los países en Latinoamérica
tienen dos problemas muy importantes: pobreza
y economía sumergida.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el 67% de los
colombianos gana menos de 140 euros al mes.
Además, se calcula que el 54% de toda la
economía colombiana es informal.
Y sí, en este 54% es donde estarían todos
los narcos que han hecho tristemente famoso
a este país.
A todo esto hay que sumarle la corrupción
política, que se lleva miles de millones
de dólares cada año.
Como os podéis imaginar, en esta situación
es muy difícil recaudar impuestos por las
vias convencionales.
Y diréis: entonces ¿De dónde saca el dinero
el Estado Colombiano?
Pues... básicamente, de donde puede.
Como no pueden poner impuesto a la renta,
Colombia tiene uno de los impuestos al consumo
más altos de Latinoamérica.
Casi todos los productos de consumo están
grabados a un 19%.
Por otro lado, Colombia también tiene un
impuesto de sociedades muy alto.
Altísimo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, las empresas
formales pueden llegar a pagar hasta un 71,9%
de impuesto de sociedades.
Por comparar, el tipo general de sociedades
en España está en el 25%.
Como os podéis imaginar, esto es un problema.
Por un lado, el Gobierno de Iván Duque quiere
bajar los impuestos a las empresas para intentar
crear nuevos sectores económicos.
Por el otro, necesita buscar otras formas
de recaudar.
Dicho de otra forma, que Colombia arrastra
un problema fiscal desde hace décadas.
Sin embargo, dentro de lo que cabe, Colombia
era capaz de cuadrar las cuentas... hasta
que llegó la pandemia.
Y como ha ocurrido en todos los países del
mundo, la factura del Coronavirus no es barata.
Gasto público durante la pandemia en Colombia
asciende a 34,6 billones de pesos
Para que os hagáis una idea, esos 34,6 billones
de pesos equivalen a más de 9.000 millones
de dólares.
Y esto es sólo el principio.
Colombia va a tener que gastar mucho más
dinero en asistencia sanitaria y ayudas económicas
¿Y de dónde saca el dinero Colombia?
Pues, principalmente, emitiendo deuda ¿El
problema?
Pues aquí tenéis el problema.
La deuda Colombiana ya se está vendiendo
como bono basura
Los intereses del bono de deuda colombiano
no paran de subir.
Es decir, que cuanto más dinero piden prestado,
más intereses se comprometen a pagar.
¿Qué puede hacer el Gobierno de Iván Duque
para evitar todo esto?
Pues simple y llanamente, recaudar más impuestos.
De esta forma, el estado tendrá que pedir
menos deuda.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el Gobierno
necesita subir la recaudación en 6.850 millones
de dólares.
Y eso explica esta medida.
Duque trata de impulsar una nueva reforma
tributaria en Colombia
Y diréis ¿Cómo se pueden subir los impuestos
en un país como Colombia?
El plan de Duque se basa en tres patas.
Por un lado, quiere bajar los impuestos a
las empresas, sobretodo las tecnológicas:
lo que el llama la “economía naranja”.
Eso tiene bastante lógica de cara al crecimiento
económico.
Y diréis ¿Pero no se supone que Duque tiene
que aumentar la recaudación?
Pues sí.
Y aquí es donde viene la parte más controvertida.
Por un lado, Duque quiere subir los impuestos
a las clases medias.
Hasta ahora, sólo pagaban impuesto sobre
la renta las personas que cobraban más de
4.700.000 pesos colombianos (es decir, unos
1200 dólares).
Pues bien, con esta reforma, se empezaría
a pagar impuesto de la renta a partir de los
2.300.000 pesos (es decir, unos 600 dólares)
¡Pero su plan no se queda aquí!
Como decíamos, Colombia tiene unos de los
impuestos al consumo más altos de Latinoamérica.
SIn embargo, hay un montón de productos que
tienen reducciones.
Pues bien, Duque quiere subir casi todos.
Por ejemplo, los ordenadores tenían un impuesto
reducido y ahora pasarían a tener un tipo
general del 19%.
Productos básicos como leche o huevos, que
estaban libres de impuestos, ahora tendrían
un 5% de tributación.
Y aquí es donde llega la gran polémica.
Porque, casi todos estos impuestos afectan
principalmente a las clases medias y las clases
bajas.
Y esto es lo que provocó las primeras protestas.
Y diréis ¿Qué ha pasado después?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
UN DEBATE ERRÓNEO
Da igual si la reforma fiscal de Duque era
buena o mala.
Tras las primeras protestas, el Gobierno la
ha retirado.
Atentos.
Duque cede a las protestas y retira la reforma
tributaria de Colombia
Habéis oído bien: el gobierno ha escuchado
a los manifestantes y ha propuesto un diálogo
con los principales sindicatos para sacar
otra reforma fiscal distinta.
Sin embargo, en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo, Colombia sigue teniendo protestas.
Y diréis ¿Por qué protestan ahora?
Parte de las razones es que estos sindicatos
sólo representan a una minoría de los manifestantes.
Pero la razón principal es esta.
Colombia eleva a 47 los muertos en las protestas
contra el presidente Duque
Habéis oído bien: en el momento en el que
hacemos este vídeo, hay más de 47 civiles
asesinados por la policía y 800 heridos.
La policía antidisturbios colombiana, el
terrible ESMAD, ha llegado a torturar a muchos
de los manifestantes ¡Pero esperad un momento!
Como os podéis imaginar, toda esta violencia
por parte de la policía no ha surgido de
la nada.
Esta historia no es tan simple como “policía
malvada contra unos pobres manifestantes pacíficos”.
Atentos.
Dos muertos y casi un centenar de policías
heridos en las protestas en Colombia por la
reforma tributaria
Decíamos que Colombia tiene dos caras.
Y esta historia también tiene dos caras.
Por un lado, es innegable que Colombia tiene
un problema de brutalidad policial.
Para que os hagáis una idea, las fuerzas
antidisturbios utilizan armas como esta para
reprimir las manifestaciones.
Esto que estáis viendo es el llamado “VENOM”.
Un lanzacohetes no letales para protestas.
Es decir, es un arma pensada para parar a
manifestantes sin matarlos ¿El problema?
El problema es que los misiles deben lanzarse
de forma parabólica.
Sin embargo, se han reportado varios casos
donde la policía la ha usado para disparar
directamente a ciudadanos.
Y en estos casos, el Venom puede ser letal.
Y diréis ¿Pero por qué es tan violenta
la policía colombiana?
Y aquí es cuando llegamos a la parte realmente
interesante de este vídeo.
Puede que os sorprenda pero hay más colombianos
con pistolas que Colombianos pagando impuesto
de la renta.
. Según la Fundación “Ideas para la Paz”,
casi 5 millones de Colombianos tienen armas
de fuego ilegales.
Todo esto es la consecuencia de vivir en uno
de los países más violentos del mundo.
No sólo hablamos de los narcotraficantes
sino también de grupos terroristas como las
FARC, el ELN y un sinfín de grupos paramilitares.
De hecho, mucha gente dice que hay infiltrados
de estos grupos entre los manifestantes ¿Tienen
razón?
En este momento no podemos confirmar nada.
Pero no es una teoría descabellada.
Los grupos terroristas no desaparecen de la
noche a la mañana.
Y es más que razonable pensar que algunos
integrantes de estos grupos se hayan unido
a las protestas con armas.
Todo esto explica que la policía Colombiana
se parezca más a un ejército que a una policía
normal.
Y no exagero en absoluto.
Veréis, en casi todos los países del mundo,
la policía forma parte del Ministerio del
Interior.
En Colombia, sin embargo, están en el ministerio
de Defensa.
Es decir, que el ejército y la policía están
mucho más unidos en este país que en cualquier
otro.
Y todo esto explica noticias como esta.
Más de 1.000 hombres de las Fuerzas Militares
y el Ejército llegarán a reforzar la seguridad
en Cali
Y aquí es cuando podemos entrar en el eterno
debate de quién tiene la razón ¿Policía
y ejército o manifestantes?
Y la respuesta es que ninguno.
Pensadlo bien: el papel de la policía es
proteger a los ciudadanos.
Es decir, proteger a los buenos y detener
a los malos.
En este caso estamos viendo todo lo contrario.
Los violentos siguen en la calle, convirtiendo
a Colombia en uno de los países más peligrosos
del mundo.
Sin embargo, muchos inocentes van a la cárcel,
sufren torturas o incluso mueren.
Todo esto tiene un nombre.
Un nombre que genera pocos titulares y que
rara vez se convertiría en trending topic
en Twitter.
No, no es ni “policía asesina” ni “SOS
Colombia”.
El auténtico nombre es “MALA GESTIÓN”.
Sí.
La policía y el ejército colombiano necesitan
modernizarse.
Y diréis ¿Por qué no lo hacen?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA DOCTRINA DAMASCO
Como hemos dicho, en Colombia, la policía
y el ejército van de la mano.
Y diréis ¿Cómo es el ejército Colombiano?
Pues hablamos de un ejército especializado
en una única cosa: operaciones especiales.
Habéis oído bien.
Tras años de guerrillas en la selva, el ejército
colombiano es experto en operaciones en la
selva.
Por ejemplo, los “comandos jungla” son
especialistas en encontrar a los narcos perdidos
en la selva ¿El problema?
Que un ejército tiene que ser capaz de hacer
más cosas.
Por ejemplo, la OTAN lleva años intentando
colaborar con el ejército colombiano en operaciones
internacionales.
Pero Colombia todavía no está preparada
para eso.
Y así es como, en el año 2011, surgió esta
estrategia.
Colombia abandona la doctrina military de
la Guerra fría y se prepara para el siglo
Os presento la doctrina Damasco.
Probablemente nunca hayáis oído hablar de
ella… aunque viváis en Colombia.
Pero la doctrina Damasco era el intento de
Colombia de modernizar su ejército.
Y diréis ¿Pero qué es una doctrina militar?
Pues una doctrina militar es el conjunto de
manuales, procesos, estategias y tácticas
que guía a un ejército.
Es decir, un ejército moderno como pueda
ser el de Estados Unidos o el de Israel no
toma decisiones de forma improvisada.
Todo está estandarizado en unos manuales
y en unos protocolos.
De esta forma, todas las unidades se pueden
poner de acuerdo.
Si miráis un manual de doctrina militar encontraréis
que todo está explicado hasta el más mínimo
detalle.
Por ejemplo, podéis ver cómo tiene que moverse
un avión de combate para disparar un objetivo
concreto.
Y diréis ¿Todo esto qué tiene que ver con
las protestas?
Pues mucho.
Porque la Doctrina Damasco no sólo está
pensada para guerras convencionales sino también
para protección civil.
Concretamente, incluye todo un protocolo llamado
“la ACCIÓN UNIFICADA”.
Este protocolo indica perfectamente cómo
se pueden poner de acuerdo la policía, los
antidisturbios y el ejército.
Indica a la perfección cómo se pueden detectar
los grupos violentos en una manifestación
sin atacar a los pacíficos.
Incluso explica con todo lujo de detalles
cómo entrenar a los soldados para evitar
violaciones de derechos humanos.
Es decir, cómo evitar la improvisación en
una situación de riesgo.
Pensadlo así: poneros por un momento en la
piel de un policía que está en mitad de
una manifestación donde hay gente armado
¿Cómo reaccionaríais si os vierais en una
situación así?
Pues bien, si os han entrenado bien, deberíais
tener un protocolo de actuación claro.
Deberíais saber qué tenéis que hacer en
ese momento para no terminar eligiendo entre
morir o matar.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando ¿Por qué
no ha servido esta Doctrina Damasco para evitar
la ultra violencia en las protestas de Colombia?
Pues atentos…
General Zapateiro tomó posesión como comandante
del Ejército pese a escándalo
En diciembre de 2019, Colombia nombró a un
nuevo jefe del ejército: el general ZAPATEIRO.
Y este es el responsable de dar al traste
con todo este proceso de modernización del
ejército colombiano.
Y aquí es donde llegamos al debate realmente
importante en Colombia.
Por un lado, tenemos a un sector del ejército
que quiere modernizarse con estrategias y
doctrinas militares homologables con la OTAN.
Por el otro tenemos al sector más tradicional
que no quiere hacer el más mínimo cambio.
Ese sector estaría encabezado por el General
Zapateiro ¿Conclusión?
Colombia sigue teniendo un ejército y una
policía que no está preparada para gestionar
unas protestas.
Y todo esto significa que, lo que podrían
haber sido un simple protesta, se haya convertido
en una guerra urbana.
Una guerra que ha puesto al Gobierno contra
las cuerdas.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Creéis que habríamos visto una situación
diferente si el ejército hubiera mantenido
la Doctrina Damasco?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Cómo puede
solucionar Colombia su problema fiscal?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis que en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.